Yeah right who's next time Tony alright
I got a little dictionary update
merriam-webster now instance word of the
year and it's gonna surprise some people
because it's a pronoun the pronoun they
now this is the word that can be used to
refer to one person whose gender
identity is non-binary so he/she they
became such a popular term this year was
searches up three hundred and thirteen
percent that the Agusta dictionary
merriam-webster decided that they had no
choice but to add it to the definition
of they and I think it's really
interesting because it goes to show how
social and political conversation and
change find their way into the our life
it does but I have to confess I'm still
trying to navigate and somebody said a
date the other day and I thought they
were talking about a group of people
yeah they were talking about one person
so I'm still trying to get onboard
yeah if you were raised with certain
grammar lesson exactly exactly yeah
every eighth grade English teacher on
board with this will be okay still
working on it